le monde ou chez pierre voici cause est
une jument de trois ans elle se fait
belle avant de monter sur le ring
elle fait partie de la trentaine de
poney shetland de bernard passionné
depuis plusieurs années dans ma fille
était petit et mais je me suis fait
plaisir autant que je désire à elle en
achetant une première poneys shetland 1
qui lui a donné un peu de fil à retordre
mais qu'elle a monté les faits beaucoup
de promenades était bien le musée après
et à partir de là quand je suis arrivé à
la retraite
eh ben j'ai créé mon petit élevage de
poneys shetland trois autres juments se
sont opposés à cosette dans sa section
dimanche à lignières l equel que 60
autres poney shetland sont jugés en main
et examiné individuellement au pas au
trot est à l'arrêt pour l'occasion une
juge britannique a fait le déplacement
l'objectif désigner le champion de
france dans la dernière section j'ai
trouvé que les trois premiers poney
était très bien je suis à la recherche
d'un poney assez libre de mouvement et
de bonnes proportions
c'était le cas pour les trois premiers
ce que j'ai examiné aujourd'hui pour la
plupart d'entre eux sont un très bon
exemple de l'art originaire des îles
shetland au nord de l'écossé poneys sont
connus pour être les plus petits équidés
du monde
au fil des années il est devenu un
animal de loisirs et d'instruction pour
les enfants ce qui fait sa popularité à
travers le monde
c'est une des premières montures des
enfants et dans les structures équestres
on va dire que si vous avez des bons
poney shetland pour les découvertes des
enfants de l'équitation
ça va être ensuite des enfants qui vont
monter sur des plus grands poneys et
ensuite qu'ils deviendront peut-être des
grands cavaliers le championnat d'europe
sera organisé pour la première fois en
france en 2020
alors pas de temps à perdre pour les
futurs champions
je